from the coldest people
where you know who are
who end up doing what they do
to others murdering others
do you do you get a sense you've been in
this world for 30 years it's either
going to be a very simple no answer it's
going to be an answer with a lot of
explanation do you think these folks
some of them are
born
cold the way they are or do you think
it's a life experience situation just a
lot of trauma bad experience with
parents mom dad
community you know all of the things
that they experience or do you think
some of them are just called from the
day they're born
they're born bad
you really believe that
yeah i do believe that i think that you
know the kid that's pulling the legs off
of a spider today who's got potential of
becoming a killer in 20 years time and i
really believe that because
it's it's shown that um
sex offenders for instance they start
with uh animal cruelty cruelty um
lighting small fires things like that
and then it just escalates to
more sadistic behavior towards other
human beings and that's you know that's
well documented so i believe that i do
believe that some people are born bad i
believe that some kids are born into a
situation that
they make the wrong life choice they'll
go and commit a robbery they're nice
people in it you know
in essence they're a nice person but the
fact is they've got
life life choices they've got to commit
a robbery someone's stepped out they've
shot them they're stabbed and whatever
it may be did they go out their way to
do it i don't know i'm not you know i'm
not there but i do think there are some
but i think some people are definitely
born bad so if you like this sort of
short clip from an interview i did click
over here to watch the entire interview
and please don't forget to subscribe to
the channel take care everybody bye
[Music]